um we have some breaking news now going
back to the Nicola bully disappearance
story and of course all the back and
forth over the last couple of days about
the information that the police have
been revealing uh including about uh her
vulnerabilities and uh just in the last
five ten minutes Lancashire police have
referred themselves to the independent
office for police conduct over the
contact the force had with missing
mother Nicola bully on January the 10th
prior to her disappearance uh the
Watchdog said so in fact specifically
they're referring themselves based on
that initial moment when they did have
contact with Nicola bully on January the
10th not as I uh perhaps just alluded to
on whether or not they released the
wrong information or private information
and a further update on that uh that the
independent office for police conduct
has released a statement saying quote
this afternoon we received a referral
from Lancashire constabulary
constabulary regarding contact the force
had with Nicola bully on the 10th of
January prior to her disappearance we
are assessing the available information
to determine whether an investigation
into that contact may be required and if
so who should conduct the investigation
so of course quite a significant
development there where no conclusions
made yet but the independent office for
police conduct will be now investigating
the Lancashire police
constabulary to ascertain whether they
were in the wrong by not doing more when
they did first have contact with Nicola
bully on the 10th of January of course
before she did then disappear a few
weeks later and Nicola bully now been
missing of course for just over uh three
weeks